[Music]
everyday million will soon be
performing the new york stock exchange online
what with over for the 3000 companies
listed in stock exchanges
and the world hello investors decide
which starts to buy to answer this
question something in corinth first
supports what
later or and what  individuals and
institutions also to achieve
by investing in him soon of partial
series of ownership in a company
zo bye bye and staking investors by ash er
in the company success
or failure as measured by the company's
prophet
soon price is determined by the number
of buyers and  sellers training has
the hormones buyers and sellers
the price will increase and vice versa
the market price over share their for
wrappers and swat buyers and sellers
polyester and by association the company
is zo the pricing change dramatically
based on whether investor i think the
company has  a high potential for
increasing profile three centuries f
is a profile mal get investor's a to
make money by pu  rchasing thrusting squeeze
calling you within critical of time
sam in westeros a simply to grow their
money and faster and inflation
diminishes italy
parents have goal of beer in the market
which means growing their money and
after eight in criminology
performance of a company later this
idea  or bid the market it's
kind of on the leg on my investors in fact
investors break interview my groups
about the asset investors believe it is
possible to be the market by
strategically selecting specific soon
and timing of the trades
while passive investors the love is a
use  only possible to be te mark and
john subscribe the city pick up the frisbee
in the market
usually matter radiation return on
investment' darcy is the standard and
poor's 500 index
the s&p 500 is a measure of the efforts
performance of 500 of the largest
companies in  the united states
who did the bad company valuation
meaning that companies with a higher
market value
hello larger effect ani  ta simply edge
and market value corresponds to what
investors louis of a company with becomes
rather than a shot at the essequibo
sectors climate percentages market so
many small
and medieval city skinflex white
king today from parents
stil is a public attraction for those
everywhere market
anything or  a set that the bag work it be
a slogan dwelling machine in the
driver and the legging machine in the
mouth er
mini short time facts in stock
prices reflex public opinion
but about the long return to the chance
to actually reflect company's process
active investors  a to exploit the
kind of terms
rolling machine aspect of the margit they
believe on market contains in efficiency
dat stock prices at any given throne in
time mee over value some companies on
their value others or file to reflect
developments
double impact the markets active
investors hope to  explosions in
efficiency by buying soon detector
price slow to identify
other value soon theme in westgate
accomplice business operations
analyze its financial statements on
dare iced red or use our little
treasure investors by contrast powder 5
in the long time machine
effective tomorrow they believe you do
markets medical 14 efficiency is there an
idea
hi about time machine vision c balance
keeps so  of the buyer selection of such
that represents a cross section of the
market
over time table bureau this is julia
complex woman index fund collections of
starks
de wrappers en to broaden my god die s&p
500 index is one of many indexus
goal is everywhere is a  especially index of
the dog tax for the long time and
techno show time marketwatch missions
ultimately
active and passive investing of michelin
exclusive many investment strategies the
element evic for simple
choosing stocks actively with holding him
for the long time passes investing and
advices
investing is for families and  science of
there was one full professor and
injured be doing
he samurai trip to yo  u into a company
that seems a little while
sketchy donut northern and flex check out
this video to understand how to identify
a pure maybe
or further your understanding of
heldenstad clockworks met this video